it's not clear that all american car
makers are committed to the luxury
strategy but you managed to get this
investment out of at a GM how how
committed are you to being a true luxury
brand well I think says it all when we
are expanding into eight new products
and covering five new segments where we
are not represented and it's an
important part of our strategy to take
Cadillac global so we need to cover the
spectrum of the order business and we
are deeply immersed taking Cadillac
right back to the pinnacle of premium
now Cadillac has been focused of the CTS
and the 80s really more on the driver
than a luxury experience / saves more of
a performance experience with this new
car you're trying to integrate those two
well what we have here is our new
flagship which obviously is placed in a
market segment where luxury refinement
and sophistication are important but
Cadillac is making our days of drivers
costs and so with the dramatic weight
reduction coming from the technology
that we deploying in this vehicle it
allows us to have tremendous agility
especially coupled with the oil steering
and we don't have to make the suspension
work quite as hard so you can have more
compliant settings it's not quite as
taut and so you have great dynamics
great luxury refinement and comfort a
true Cadillac it's actually the
lightweight technology is shocking you
don't talk about it as much as others
talk about their aluminum structures but
you've got this car down to 3,700 pounds
which is that's that's Porsche territory
really i mean that's lighter than a BMW
7-series in audi a8 but also a BMW
5-series now dat six I mean what does
that mean 3,700 pounds for such a big
car yeah so that Porsche that will be in
this territory is also a lot smaller
than this car and the answer really lies
in the Panamera it's much lighter than a
Panamera which gets over 4,000 pounds
that's right and so we are able to use a
mixed materials approach where we
actually apply each different kind of
material to its particular function not
all materials are equally suited for all
applications and so if you make an
all-aluminium car you compromise on some
things we wanted to get
wait we wanted to get maximum body
rigidity stiffness crash performance and
the real breakthrough is in our ability
to bond these 13 kinds of materials so
it's as much the manufacturing
technology as the vehicle technology
that breakthrough science here the the
technology in the vehicle as far as
high-tech is also impressive it's the
first car ever the 360-degree recording
video camera so if anyone bumps into you
on the RFK bridge like happened to me
last week you would actually have that
recorded for insurance purposes it's
also got massaging and reclining seats
in the back so you really gone all out
it's a Cadillac and it's a flagship it's
a luxury-car sophisticated refinement
performance you got it all how do you
the one thing that you've got to work on
I mean you've got it down obviously the
car but the image is it has always been
an issue for Cadillac at least in recent
years how do you plan to tackle the
image problem I think if your camera
pans around this stand you'll see how we
are going to make cars that take on the
very best with vehicles that will when
you've got in this car right now v6 twin
turbocharged v6 and a bigger naturally
aspirated v6 do we get to see a Corvette
engine in here we get to see the big 6.2
liter v8 no I think what this call once
is a really high-tech very advanced
twin-turbo v8 and if we little bit
patient it'll come and and what about an
electric or a hybrid drivetrain Cadillac
is fully committed to utilizing our
plug-in hybrid vehicle technology
virtually across our entire lineup they
won't all be available tomorrow morning
but over the next few years I think that
we will see this technology employed
deployed across the road do you know the
car the cars have been so successful as
far as the products and the critics are
concerned but the sales numbers haven't
been fantastic what do you think you can
deal with Cadillac this year's far sales
well sales last year on a global basis
grew around six percent i expect that
same trend to continue we should be
careful that we don't measure
Cadillac just by what's going on the
u.s. is a global business and we have
the luxury now of enjoying strong growth
in other regions of the world which
allows us to consolidate our American
operations and really focus on getting
the quality of the business is a solid
foundation on which to launch our future
growth plans so right now plans are on
track I am NOT chasing volume I am
building a powerful brand and it starts
by presenting superlative products at
competitive price points no incentives